it's the confession game okay okay you
ready
[Music]
no house party is complete without
karaoke what is your go-to karaoke song
hmm that's a good question I don't know
uh sure
what's the one 7 o'clock on the dot what
is your guilty pleasure hmm chocolate
milk
that's your guilty pleasure yeah but
lots of it I mean the big glass bottle
some whole foods if he's never had their
glass bottle chocolate milk
it's okay I'll drink to that yeah and
then it's your guilty pleasure okay
[Applause]
I smile
let's take your heart
take your most prized possession hmm
probably an acoustic guitar
you know I'm written most every song
I've ever worked on phone yeah and it
has become more important to me that as
my career has come along sit here yeah
nicely yeah I'm playing this right there
ultimate cheat meal I don't have a super
strict diet I really like I like hot
wings I can eat a lot of prey or do
nothing else will work other than always
so yeah hot wings nice I like that one
biggest fear maybe sharks maybe I don't
know yeah I guess yeah yeah I didn't
Excel but we were swimming in Hawaii
recently at night and I realize it a
lotta big fan of Shores
tray
worst job you've ever had I work for a
moving company for a while in college
and it was it was rough I mean we were
moving like three or four houses a day
big loads that's it
[Music]
you